hello to the intro
Gregory Elbe yo us i J
justice J justice J justice Johnny hey I
don't know what this name weird intro
for a low Joneses weird trailer for
Captain America Civil War everyone's
excited about this people are really
telling me Greg you gotta watch this
[ __ ] let's play it John my best friend
in the whole world on things man
ah-ah-ah mom's name is Sara he used to
wear newspapers
ah the people who think you do to come
right back
subscribe bye everyone whoa dark huh
oh hey I think for either for the word
vigilant
Oh God we need a source you saying
you'll arrest me
haha yeah you can expect limitations in
a very bad master
that's not the way sometimes I want to
punch from your personal oh wow Oh No
not the one that needs to watch their
back
this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
you just started warning
yeah [ __ ] out final word I could do this
all day
whoa that'd be cool that would be
awesome
oh it's awesome
I've run out of patience underoos
dude elder Jones you my man oh dear
please go to a patron patreon you say
what you get a patron I'm playing this
to me after the show dear good
I feel like overwhelmed with joy right
now yeah that was awesome
Aldo first they're gonna say what was
the acronym you put for react real
emotions are carefully taken cheerfully
cheerfully real emotions are cheerfully
take did it sound good
I [ __ ] love that that's really smart
that is a great acronym yeah given the
state of things it's a smart idea it's
so cool to see a the support of you know
what you have four reaction channels you
know like I'm grateful for the channel
we have in it I'm so so grateful for the
Chad I love this channel I do I love
this Chapel you don't tell you guys
enough we feel like it's like some guy
goofy youtuber thing is they you know
what I would watch like people on
YouTube and they'd be like I love you
guys I'd be like you really are you just
saying that just because you know the
thing to say to your subscribers but I
genuinely love each and every one of you
subscribers the nice ones well you know
I mean anybody who's supportive and you
know is crazy I have to believe in this
little thing that's what this video
makes me feel thankful beyond the react
part I think it's amazing how he had the
BVS won't come out which was my you know
but I get awesome yeah and then Suicide
Squad was more debatable in terms of
like how do we really feel about it that
I think he liked learned some stuff
because things
about it that he did different that
worked and some things about it work I
noticed some people are not completely
on board for it's still good still
better than anything I've ever [ __ ]
creating so yeah this one was great well
then is this struck the perfect tone cos
a it's a rather serious trailer yeah but
it's fast enough to work with his style
I feel like what the first one does
really well and what this one does
really well by the end of it is it finds
these jokes and actually has fun with
them and plays them out it does a couple
rips on them it's a suicide by one I
felt just like some of the stuff was
just sort of random references and this
video kind of started that way for me
but then like when it got to be a
quarter of the way and it started to lay
down these jokes in rhythm and and you
know building on ideas in it it became
really fun and engaging yeah I think
this is kind of clever like this might
be his best editing he's ever done
actually once he actually starts
throwing in stuff that changes the tone
of the actual trailer yeah it doesn't
just make it wacky like it becomes
actually kind of cool and I think it has
a nice light touch of upping the quality
but not too much to the point where it
loses the personal touch yeah yeah that
was kind of the fun of the BVS one was
it like it isn't exactly the greatest at
times but it makes it that much more
funny when it's just so out of place
well and it's absurd but it's like
appropriately absurd yeah exactly so
he's up in the quality in like the right
ways but I don't want to go like too pro
you know cuz like that's part of the
charm is the sort of you know I can feel
the hands that made this want to meet
you Aldo Jones I want to give you a big
hug yeah kiss you bear hug in a manly
kissing cheek way so you'll probably be
like slapping his other cheek and yeah
I'm saying something Italian you never
see an interview without no Will Smith
where a guy like kissed him on the cheek
the interviewer the interviewer kissed
the and listen there's like what's wrong
with you things smacked them like that
no I'd never heard of yeah oh wow yeah
that's boo you'll have to show me that
it's dead shot for you listen guys um
aldo jones subscribe to his channel link
in description box hey if you knew this
show you can subscribe to day become
reject
we're like everyone likes Will Smith but
nobody knows quite where he's been the
last few movies I've been doing our
group let's wrap this up listen guys um
aldo Jones subscribed to his channel
link in description box hey if you knew
this channel you can subscribe to day
become reject John has a play that's got
reasons to Jerry yes don't worry about
the name thing stop asking yeah please
day gasp Stubbs podcast subsidized John
can and you can follow us facebook.com
slash the real rejects Instagram at the
Greg Alva reasons to Jerry reason see
Jerry and Twitter calm will reject the
real rejects that's Greg Alba my reasons
cherry and until I change it I want to
give shout out shout out to Aldo Jones's
girlfriend what I hope the two you have
a wonderful anniversary this coming
month you deserve each other
may God how'd it happen [ __ ] you what
did you do